[Musica]
sedetevi in una posizione comoda con la
colonna vertebrale eretto
nei fatti un profondo respiro
è un profondo respiro e chiudi i tuoi
occhi
le porta tutta l'attenzione in questo
istante
ha la sensazione
che l'aria ti fa sentire entrando e
uscendo dalle tue analisi
fa in modo che il tuo respiro sia sempre
più lento
rilassato profondo naturale
e prendi coscienza del miracolo della
vita
fa in modo che ogni ispirazione
tu possa accogliere la vita come se
fosse il primo respiro
il primo respiro della tua vita ora
è ad ogni ispirazione
lascia andare ogni tensione
e fa in modo che sia come l'ultimo
respiro
con quella stessa intensità quando la
tua vita si farà dono
in questo momento lentamente
appoggia le mani nel tuo cuore
mantenendo gli occhi chiusi con
gentilezza
e semplicemente pensa e chi ama una
persona che ami o hai amato
profondamente anche se non è più qui con
te può essere la tua mamma tuo padre
un fratello una sorella un nonno un
figlio anche un figlio mai avuto anche
un figlio perduto
e guarda questa persona mentre si
avvicina a te ti sorride
e condividi questo spazio al di là del
tempo con lei
guarda la
guardano negli occhi come se fosse
l'ultimo saluto
l'ultimo istante
edile semplicemente queste
semplici parole di leh io ti chiedo
perdono
per tutto il tempo che non tornerà per
il tempo sprecato
per ogni volta che non ti ho detto ti
amo per i silenzi io ti chiedo perdono
edile
grazie per la tua vita
grazie per ogni istante che ci è stato
concesso grazie per il dolore grazie per
l'amore
in questo istante ringraziano per ciò
che vuoi per le ultime cose
[Musica]
inspira profondamente
mantenendo gli occhi chiusi e ispirando
aprile tue mani e don hall e dal tuo
cuore la luce di questo istant la luce
di questo momento che puoi condividere
attraverso il respiro vita nella vita e
guarda questa persona che prende nelle
sue mani
questo donna lo porta nel suo cuore in
questo istante
è semplicemente deal
io ti lascio andare gli occhi libero
inspira profondamente insieme a me
e sofia adesso
le guarda questa persona che
vola via libera
lasciala andare una via libera nel posto
più elevato
dove può ricevere in questo istante ciò
che avrebbe voluto darti sicurezza forza
salute guarigione
lasciala andare e torna ancora un
istante in questo momento in questo
respiro
e prendi coscienza
di esistere e di avere il dono della
vita proprio ora
fermati un istante
fermati un istante respira
e fai tra i profondi respiri profondi
profondi e al terzo espirando dalla
bocca semplicemente apri i tuoi occhi
e torna qui
inspira espira dalla bocca e apri gli
occhi
ho respirato in molte carceri
condividendo con i detenuti i programmi
di meditazione di perdono e di
respirazione consapevole
non so se avete presente l'odore di un
carcere però rimane addosso e detenuti
per tanto tempo anche dopo che escono è
un odore che racconta molte cose
soprattutto racconta silenzio acconta
rabbia racconta violenze
la prima volta che sono entrato in un
carcere avevo circa 100 detenuti davanti
ho sentito subito un senso di
oppressione forte al cuore tanto che
credevo che mi stesse venendo un infarto
e
ricordo due cose di quelle esperienze
l'assenza di colore e l'odore ad ore che
non volevo respirare non volevo
ricordare soprattutto perché non avrei
mai voluto sentire con le storie e
quella violenza è più il mio rifiuto
diventava profondo io non volevo che la
vita penetrasse in me portando con
l'informazione quei vissuti più questo
dolore aumentava il respiro si faceva
corto poi ho capito ho capito cosa mi fa
cosa stava accadendo e mi sono fermato
un istante
li ho guardati tutti negli occhi poi ho
fatto
è sfilato più profondamente che è che ho
potuto li ho portati tutti dentro di me
attraverso un respiro ho scelto di
ascoltarlo quel disagio e ho capito
attraverso un respiro che quel senso di
oppressione
era il mio rifiuto che lo stava creando
la distanza che avevo creato tra me e
loro trame la vita e soprattutto tutto
tra me e me stesso
non so se avete mai condiviso un istante
di respirazione consapevole con una
persona magari con la persona che amate
è qualcosa di estremamente intimo di
estremamente gentile perché condividi la
vita
è uno spazio che si crea dove non c'è
più passato e i suoi fantasmi non c'è
neanche futuro le sue preoccupazioni
tutto quello che conta è quanto
intensamente riusciamo a portarci in
quell'istante insieme il respiro
consapevole e vita libera che rompe io
tu dentro fuori vittima carnefice è
quanto è incredibile il miracolo della
vita in un respiro e la vita che si
respira che si respira a tutti in realtà
non possiamo controllare niente nella
nostra esistenza
in realtà il respiro consapevole la vita
che ci assolve tutti e quando iniziato a
respirare con i carcerati e accaduto
questo che attraverso il respiro li ha
incontrati nella vita senza più sbarre
mentali e anche quel dolore anche
quell'odore per me e per loro è
diventato casa
trova a fermarti un istante adesso a
respirare respira adesso insieme a me
però fare una profonda ispirazione
ed espirando alla bocca a fare questa
prova lasciare andare
noi respiriamo
21.600 volte al giorno
quanti di questi respiri sono
consapevoli vi rendete conto che ognuno
di questi respiri potrebbe essere una
preghiera quando tu sei grato per ogni
respiro ancora concesso e avrà il tempo
in cui non potrai più farlo quel respiro
si fa preghiera quando tu sei
consapevole abiti consapevolmente il
respiro attraverso la gratitudine la
gentilezza
accogliendo la vita lasciando che la
vita ti respiri quel respiro si fa
preghiera e anche quando ami la vita nel
dolore nell'amore attraverso quel
respiro quel respiro diventa preghiera
il respiro è nutrimento ogni
respirazione che tu fai contribuisce
alla combustione di glucosio di ossigeno
ed è come mangiare tu puoi mangiare
distratto con pensieri disfunzionali
guardando la televisione oppure può
essere estremamente presente in quello
che sta accadendo in questo istante
trasformando la respirazione in una
forma profonda di alimentazione di
gratitudine di sacralità di ritualità
nella vita e c'è un nesso ho messo
speciale intimissimo tra emozione e
respirazione e così come è vero che
emozioni come la rabbia come la paura
come la colpa rendono il nostro respiro
corto
e clavicolare è anche vero il contrario
che respira uno strumento di
trasformazione alchemica profondissima
del nostro ambiente interiore dei nostri
stati d'animo delle nostre emozioni e
noi possiamo esplorare al posto che
rifiutare la rabbia perché la rabbia in
sé non è positiva o negativa e ciò che
tu fai della rabbia e lo spirito con cui
abiti la vita a dare il senso alle cose
e alla vita stessa se tu abiti la rabbia
e regolando il respiro in quella rabbia
in intensità in ritmo un'intenzionalità
profonda to trasformi la rabbia in
determinazione in ascolto in un qualcosa
che non ti allontana ma ti avvicina a te
stesso così come trasformi lance è in
espansione la paura in amore questa è la
potenza del respiro prova a fermarti
adesso un istante ea celebrare insieme
un respiro consapevole prova inspirare
insieme a me ora inspira
lascia andare
nella mia esistenza ho
capito l'importanza del respiro
attraverso una linea di ricerca molto
particolare c'è l'accompagnamento alla
morte e l'elaborazione del lutto del
dolore della sofferenza
ho accompagnato tante persone nel fine
vita ma sette anni fa mi è accaduto
forse l'accompagnamento più importante e
significativo della mia vita perché
stato un amico carissimo regista
spagnolo che il giorno del mio
compleanno
il 19 di settembre nel caso nel caso mi
ha chiamato e la mattina mi dice
nel suo perfetto stile dice volevo farti
gli auguri per il tuo compleanno e poi
ha detto un tumore al pancreas
ne hanno dato meno di un mese volevo
credere alle sue parole mi ha dato meno
di un mese di vita e poi mi ha fatto una
richiesta che mi ha scioccato
mi ha detto voglio morire in pace voglio
che sia tu ad aiutarmi a fare questo
aspetta un attimo devo prendermi un
attimo di tempo ho chiuso il telefono
stato confusionale mi sono seduto a
meditare e poi ho deciso scelta ho
disdetto tutti gli appuntamenti
lavorativi di quel mese ho preso un
aereo e sono andato a barcellona a casa
sua lui ha aperto la porta ci siamo
guardati
e poi abbiamo iniziato un lavoro di di
perdono e di respirazione molto profonda
per entrare nella vita non per celebrare
la morte ma trent rare nella vita e lui
ha rivissuto tutta la sua esistenza
tutto quello che aveva lasciato sospeso
e attraverso ogni respiro ha lasciato
andare ha perdonato e poi più si
alleggeriva più il suo corpo si
deteriorava più il suo sguardo diventava
vivo era il paradossale finché una
settimana prima di morire per avanzi
tutti spesso accadeva la sera non è
silenzio delle sue poltrone in questi
giardini meravigliosi del che si
affacciavano nella barcellona interna e
lui si gira mi guarda con uno sguardo
che non dimenticherò mai
se mi disse non sono mai stato così
felice nella mia vita e lo guardo ti ho
detto
tu stai lasciando tua figlia che ha 8
anni
tuo figlio ne ha 12 il tuo corpo non è
più neanche la salute non puoi neanche
più muoverti ma mai prospettive per il
futuro quindi dice che sei felice detto
ti prego dimmi di che felicità si tratta
perché voglio voglio voglio conoscerla
ci sono alcuni di noi che sono maestri
durante il corso della vita lui è stato
il maestro durante il corso della sua
morte di lui mi ha detto ho sempre
creduto che la felicità in questa
esistenza fosse data da ciò che potevo
non potevo fare da ciò che potevo non
potevo avere dalla salute dai figli dal
lavoro dal successo solo adesso mi sono
reso conto che dipende da quanto
intensamente sono sveglio e presente nel
miracolo della vita in ogni respiro
ancora consesso che non do per scontato
mi ha detto mi dispiace essermi reso
conto solo adesso che tutto intorno a me
l'amore non riuscivo a vederlo
e poi io l'ho dovuto salutare questo è
stato il suo più grande insegnamento è
il giorno dopo sono andato via ho
lasciato che la famiglia
venisse lui è riuscito a morire in pace
in uno stato di grazia lui era seduto
nel suo letto ci siamo guardati non è
nella porta di casa sua il sun guardati
per un tempo infinito infinitamente
lungo
sapevamo che era l'ultimo sguardo
l'ultimo saluto
io credevo che fosse celebrato
attraverso i silenzi invece l'ultima
parola lui me l'ha voluta dire e mi ha
guardato e mi ha detto questa sera
racconta llano io vi ringrazio perché
oggi potendo di raccontare questo
questa storia così intima della mia vita
io posso mantenere fede a questa
promessa buon respiro a tutti
[Applauso]